OK. So here's a story you probably heard and a story you have not. Remember in 2018 when Hawaiians got that alert on their phones saying that a ballistic missile was inbound, headed for Hawaii, this is not a drill, seek immediate shelter. People scrambled to find places to hide. They put their kids in storm drains. It seemed completely plausible that a missile was on the way because this was after months of President Trump and North Korea's leader Kim Jong-un threatening each other with nuclear destruction, fire, and fury. OK, so that is the story you know. Here's the one you don't.
好的，接下来的故事你可能听过，也可能没听过。还记得2018年吗，当时夏威夷人的手机上收到了一条警报，说有一枚弹道导弹正在飞向夏威夷，这不是演习，请立即寻找避难所。人们争先恐后地寻找躲藏的地方，甚至把孩子塞进下水道。导弹来袭看起来完全真实可信，因为那是在特朗普总统和朝鲜领导人金正恩互相威胁要以核毁灭、战火和愤怒摧毁对方之后的几个月。好的，这就是你们知道的故事。接下来是你们不知道的那个。
When the alert came, I was at my house up on my lawn. My first thought was, wow, I'm going to view history and then get wiped off the map.
警报响起时，我正在家里的草坪上。我第一个念头是：哇，我即将见证历史，然后从地图上被抹去。
This is Mike McFarland. And he figured he'd be viewing history because his lawn is in a part of Oahu that overlooks Pearl Harbor, which is where he figured the missile was going to land. There's still an active military base there. So he grabs his cat to bring her inside, flips on TV and radio. The same alert, "Incoming missile," is everywhere, which makes it more real and more terrifying. He props up an iPad at a window and points it at Pearl Harbor to live stream whatever's about to happen, which he admits--
这位是麦克·麦克法兰。他觉得自己会见证历史，因为他的草坪位于瓦胡岛上，可以俯瞰珍珠港，他认为导弹会落在那儿。那里现在还有一个现役军事基地。于是，他抓起猫带进屋，打开电视和收音机。同样的“导弹来袭”警报到处都是，这让情况变得更加真实，也更加恐怖。他在窗边架起一台iPad，对着珍珠港进行直播，准备记录即将发生的一切，对此他承认——
Like, I'm not rational. I just got the news my world was going to end. Now I have about 15 minutes to live, in my mind. And--
就像，我不理智了。我刚收到消息说我的世界要终结了。现在我心想，我大概还有15分钟活头。而且——
He starts thinking about his life and his grandfather, who died when he was little, and some whiskey of his grandfather's that he still had somewhere.
他开始想起自己的人生，想起他小时候就去世的祖父，以及他依然藏在某处的祖父留下的威士忌。
--grab. I found this thing. It's been up in the closet. And it's the beautiful bottle. And I took a big drink. And I toasted my grandfather and said, OK, goodbye. This is it. And then, I read this article once, that how you survive a nuclear blast. And it just kind of came out of nowhere from the dark reaches of my mind. It's when the nuclear thing comes, you're supposed to go in a bathtub and cover yourself up with a blanket. So I took my cat in there. I had my phone in there, cover myself up, and just laid there, and just waited. And--
——抓起（酒）。我发现了它。它一直放在壁橱里。那是一个漂亮的瓶子。我喝了一大口，向我的祖父敬酒说，好吧，再见。就是这样了。然后，我读过一篇文章，讲如何在核爆炸中幸存。它不知怎么地从我记忆的深处冒了出来。就是当核打击到来时，你应该钻进浴缸，用毯子盖住自己。所以我把猫带了进去。我带着手机钻进去，盖上毯子，躺在那里，等待着。而且——
By the way, and no offense to Mike, going into your bathtub will not protect you from a nuclear blast. Well, you know, it's funny where your mind goes when you think you just have minutes to live.
顺便说一句，对麦克没有冒犯的意思，躲进浴缸并不能保护你免受核爆炸的伤害。嗯，你知道，当你以为只剩下几分钟生命时，脑子里冒出的念头真是很有趣。
And I think I had the moment that a lot of people think about-- but let me tell you it's different when it happens-- it's like, OK, I'm going to die. I'm going to die right here. And my life just sort of came rushing in front of my eyes. It's like, OK, what am I proud of? What am I sorry about? And I thought about Lynn. I thought about the last girlfriend I had. And it wasn't a pretty breakup. And I felt--
我想当时我确实有了那种很多人会想到的瞬间——但让我告诉你，当事情真的发生时感觉是不一样的——就像，好吧，我要死了。我就要死在这儿了。我的人生就像走马灯一样在我眼前闪过。心想，好吧，我为自己感到骄傲的是什么？我感到遗憾的是什么？我想到了琳。我想到了我的前女友。我们的分手并不体面。我感到——
They'd broken up maybe six months before this, after a year together.
他们在一起一年后，在这件事发生前大约六个月分了手。
And I thought, OK, well, I'll just send a text to Lynn and just tell her goodbye and tell her how important she was in my life and love of my life. And so I did. I sent that.
我想，好吧，我给琳发条短信说声再见吧，告诉她她在我的生命中有多重要，她是我一生挚爱。于是我照做了。我发出了那条短信。
The exact words of the text-- "Lynn, I just got word that a nuclear missile on its way to Honolulu. I'm not sure where you are or if you'll even read this, but I thought of you. I wanted to let you know that looking back, you were the love of my life. If it is, in fact, over in a few minutes, thank you for the time we spent together." Then he lays there and waits. Before long-- 38 minutes after the original alert-- he and everybody else learned there's no incoming missile.
短信的原文是——“琳，我刚得到消息说一枚核导弹正在飞往檀香山的路上。我不确定你在哪儿，甚至不知道你是否会读到这条短信，但我想到了你。我想让你知道，回首往事，你曾是我的一生挚爱。如果这一切真的在几分钟内结束，谢谢我们在一起的时光。”然后他躺在那里等待。不久之后——在最初的警报发出38分钟后——他和所有人都知道根本没有导弹来袭。
And I have this-- I don't know if I can use this word on your station but-- oh, blank moment. It's like, oh, this is really embarrassing. It's like, I'm not dead. And I sent this message.
而我当时有一种——我不知道能不能在你们电台上用这个词，但是——哦，空白时刻。就像，噢，这太尴尬了。就像，我没死。但我却发了那条信息。
Lynn would not see this message for hours, because right when the alert came over, she was actually on the runway at Inouye Airport in Honolulu, on a flight headed to California to look at colleges with her son, who saw the first alert on his phone.
琳几个小时后才看到这条信息，因为警报响起时，她正坐在檀香山井上机场的跑道上，准备飞往加州陪儿子看大学，儿子在手机上看到了第一条警报。
He was terrified saying, my dad is dead, my friends are dead. I'm going to war, Mom. Our country is going to war. This is World War III. Ghost white, his hands were sweaty, and I'm consoling him. But in my mind, as an adult, I'm like, OK, pilots, just-- expletive-- take off. Just-- expletive- take off. Do not listen to air traffic control. Just go. Please, just go, plane.
他吓坏了，说：爸爸死了，朋友们也死了。我要去打仗了，妈妈。我们国家要开战了。这就是第三次世界大战。他脸色惨白，手心出汗，我在安慰他。但在我心里，作为一个成年人，我想的是，好吧，飞行员们，快点——该死——起飞吧。就——该死——起飞吧。别管空中交通管制。直接走。拜托，飞机快走。
It's not till they landed five hours later that Lynn sees Mike's text. Today, she remembers just one sentence of that text, the key sentence.
直到五小时后飞机降落，琳才看到麦克的短信。今天，她只记得那条短信里的一句话，最关键的一句话。
It said, "You were the love of my life."
上面写着：“你曾是我的一生挚爱。”
And what did you think when you saw that?
当你看到那句话时，你是怎么想的？
I think that we ended our relationship, for me, probably a little bit too abruptly. And I felt that perhaps there were more things to explore.
我认为我们结束那段关系，对我来说，可能有点太仓促了。我觉得也许还有更多事情值得探索。
So she was glad to see it. She wrote him back, "Let's talk." And when Lynn got back to Hawaii, she and Mike met up, hung out a bunch of times to see how it felt. And then they got back together because of that text, sent from a bathtub, under a blanket, "You were the love of my life."
所以她很高兴看到那条短信。她回信说：“我们谈谈吧。”当琳回到夏威夷后，她和麦克见了面，在一起待了好几次，感受一下那种感觉。然后他们因为那条从浴缸里、在毯子下发出的短信——“你曾是我的一生挚爱”——复合了。
Do you think you ever would have said this to her if not for the incoming nuclear attack?
你认为如果不是因为那次核袭击警报，你还会对她说出这些话吗？
Oh, absolutely not. Absolutely not. At that moment, in that moment, I was truly-- it changed for me.
噢，绝对不会。绝对不会。在那个时刻，在那一刻，我确实——那对我来说是一种改变。
It was nicer this time, being together. They were better friends, better at talking through problems. They built a massive garden together, raised nasturtiums and tons of vegetables, took care of animals at an animal rescue place. But they had their differences, and it didn't last. After maybe six months, they decided to split up on friendly terms. Lynn says she's glad they tried.
这次在一起更好了。他们成了更好的朋友，更擅长沟通解决问题。他们一起建了一个巨大的花园，种了旱金莲和成堆的蔬菜，还在动物救援中心照顾动物。但他们有分歧，这段感情没能持续下去。大约六个月后，他们决定友好分手。琳说她很高兴他们尝试过。
I would say I was definitely glad for the chance for us to give it one more shot.
我会说我绝对很高兴我们有机会再试一次。
Yeah, it's like you got to run the science experiment again just to be sure you got the same result.
是的，就像是你必须重新运行科学实验才能确定得到相同的结果一样。
[LAUGHS] I suppose.
[笑] 我想是吧。
Can I ask you, do you think he ever would have reached out if he didn't think he was going to die in a nuclear attack?
我可以问你吗，你觉得如果他没有认为自己要在核袭击中死去，他还会联系你吗？
I-- wow. Hmm. I don't know. But I may have reached out to him. But, wow, that's a great question.
我——哇。嗯。我不知道。但我可能会联系他。但是，哇，这是一个好问题。
I actually asked him. Do you want to know what he said?
我其实问过他。你想知道他是怎么说的吗？
Yeah.
想。
He said, absolutely, he never would have texted you that if he didn't think he was going to die.
他说，绝对不会，如果他不觉得自己要死了，他绝不会给你发那样的短信。
Oh, wow. OK. It makes you wonder if perhaps those words weren't real, "You were the love of my life." I don't think that if someone is the love of your life that you just let it go. So perhaps he just did it in the spur of the moment.
噢，哇。好吧。这让人不禁怀疑那句话也许不是真心的，“你曾是我的一生挚爱。”我不认为如果某人是你的一生挚爱，你会轻易放手。所以也许他只是在那一瞬间冲动之下才这么做的。
Mike says no. He says he meant what he said. It was real. He just figured they were done before that moment came that accidentally ended up bringing them back together.
麦克说不是。他说他是真心的。那是真实的。他只是觉得在那个导致他们复合的意外瞬间到来之前，他们就已经结束了。
It's so interesting to think about, there really is nothing like a deadline.
思考这件事很有趣，确实没有什么比截止日期更能促成事情了。
Exactly, and you can miss a deadline and get fired or whatever. But this deadline, I was going to die, right? I mean, it was the ultimate deadline, I guess, is the best way to say that. Right? It was the ultimate deadline. And I wish, going forward, there was a way for everybody to plug into that moment where, OK, you've got 15 minutes to truly fix things.
没错，你可能错过截止日期然后被解雇或者其他什么。但这个截止日期，我要死了，对吧？我的意思是，这是终极截止日期，我觉得这是最好的说法。对吧？这是终极截止日期。我希望以后能有一种方式让每个人都能接入那个瞬间，让你意识到，好吧，你还有15分钟来真正修复一切。
Well, today on our program, people trying to fix things at the very last minute. It is the way that so many things happen, too many things. Just this week, it seemed like the United States was going to miss one of its very last chances to get anywhere near the 2030 climate goals to hold the Earth's temperature rise at 1.5 degrees Celsius.
那么，今天在我们的节目中，我们要讲那些在最后一刻试图修复问题的人们。这也是很多事情发生的方式，太多事情了。就在本周，美国似乎要错过实现2030年气候目标（将地球升温控制在1.5摄氏度以内）的最后机会之一了。
And then, not even at the 11th hour-- it was after the clock had run out-- Senator Joe Manchin did a turnaround and agreed to legislation that would cut emissions. Why is it always like this? Today on our program, we observe the power of a crushing impeding deadline to focus the mind and lead to action. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
然后，甚至不是在最后一小时——而是在时钟已经走完之后——乔·曼钦参议员突然转变立场，同意了一项旨在削减排放的立法。为什么总是这样？今天在我们的节目中，我们要探讨迫在眉睫的最后期限如何聚焦思维并促成行动。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, A Funny Thing Happened on the Way to the Quorum.
第一幕：通往法定人数之路的趣事。
So, a bunch of people in a small town, Croydon, New Hampshire, population 800, wake up one morning not with an imaginary missile heading towards them, but something that felt, I don't know, dire, with a deadline they never saw coming. Sarah Gibson of New Hampshire Public Radio tells what happened.
一群人居住在新罕布什尔州的一个小镇克罗伊登，人口800人。一天早上醒来，迎面而来的不是虚构的导弹，而是某种让我感到，怎么说呢，可怕的事情，伴随着一个他们从未预料到的截止日期。来自新罕布什尔州公共广播电台的萨拉·吉布森讲述了发生了什么。
This story starts at a school budget meeting. In Croydon, barely anyone goes to these. Even the local TV guy, who sometimes films town meetings, did not show up this year. So there's not even a recording. But I'm going to tell you about it, because what happened that day triggered a very strange series of events.
故事始于一次学校预算会议。在克罗伊登，几乎没人参加这种会议。甚至连那个有时会拍摄镇会议的本地电视工作者今年也没现身。所以甚至连录音都没有。但我会告诉你发生了什么，因为那天发生的事引发了一系列非常奇怪的事件。
The meeting takes place at the Croydon Town Hall, an old, white building with tall windows and a big, drafty room. There's an American flag from the 1800s framed on the wall, some built-in pews, and a bunch of folding chairs. Tom Moore walks in.
会议在克罗伊登市政厅举行，那是一栋古老的白色建筑，有着高大的窗户和一个空旷通风的房间。墙上装裱着一面1800年代的美国国旗，有一些嵌入式的长椅和一堆折叠椅。汤姆·摩尔走了进去。
He's 43 years old, big, red beard, teaches high school math and woodworking, and has three little kids. Tom's been on the Croydon School Board for years. But this it's his last day. Doesn't expect anything dramatic to happen. He'd carved some wooden pens as goodbye gifts for his colleagues on the board.
他43岁，留着浓密的红胡子，教高中数学和木工，有三个小孩。汤姆在克罗伊登学校董事会任职多年。但这是他的最后一天。没料到会发生什么戏剧性的事。他雕刻了一些木笔作为给同事们的告别礼物。
And, as I walk in, I register my name and I get handed a pamphlet. And I don't really glance at it.
当我走进去时，我登记了名字，领到了一份小册子。我并没有仔细看它。
He sits down. Everything seems normal. One of the townspeople in the audience is Jim Peschke, who knows this is not going to be normal. Jim is kind of a budget nerd, obsessed with the school budget. It's the town's biggest expense by a lot. This year, it's $1.7 million, the highest it's ever been. And every year, Jim comes in with a proposal to shrink it.
他坐了下来。一切看起来都很正常。听众中的镇民之一吉姆·佩什克知道这不会正常。吉姆是个“预算书呆子”，痴迷于学校预算。这是小镇最大的开支，而且高出很多。今年是170万美元，是有史以来最高的。每年，吉姆都会带着一个削减预算的提案前来。
I, in years past, believe I've brought up $20,000 cuts that weren't approved because they were barbaric, in the words of the opponents.
过去几年，我认为我曾提出过2万美元的削减额，但没被批准，因为反对者说这太野蛮了。
Jim's an electrical engineer, a transplant from the Midwest. He and his wife pride themselves on having homeschooled their kids rather than send them to public school. A thing to know about this budget meeting-- it's not just to talk about the proposed school budget.
吉姆是一名电气工程师，从中西部搬来。他和妻子对让孩子在家教育而不是送去公立学校感到自豪。关于这个预算会议有一点要了解——它不仅仅是讨论拟议的学校预算。
The way things work here is that whoever shows up gets to actually vote on what the budget should be. This has been the approach in Croydon-- really most of small town New Hampshire-- since the 1800s. It's a relic that most people no longer participate in. Today at the town hall attendance is low, about 40 people. The meeting starts and Tom finally looks down at that pamphlet. The title is Budget or Ransom?
这里的运作方式是，任何到场的人都可以实际投票决定预算应该是多少。这是克罗伊登——实际上是新罕布什尔州大多数小镇——自1800年代以来的做法。这是一个大多数人不再参与的遗迹。今天在市政厅，出席人数很少，大约40人。会议开始，汤姆终于看了那份小册子。标题是《预算还是勒索？》。
And I go, oh, what is this? This is crazy. But as I'm looking at that, people are starting to get really upset about how much we're paying the principal and the superintendent, and about violins and snowshoes. And there just seems to be a lot of people up in arms.
我说，噢，这是什么？这太疯狂了。但当我在看那个时，人们开始对我们支付给校长和督导的薪水，以及关于小提琴和雪鞋的开支感到非常愤怒。似乎很多人都准备抗争。
The snow shoes and violins, paid for entirely with grants. But to some people here, it felt extravagant and wasteful.
小提琴和雪鞋的费用完全是由补助金支付的。但对这里的一些人来说，这感觉像是挥霍和浪费。
It's like, if you wanted to design an instrument that could be easily broken by second and third graders, it would be the violin.
就像是，如果你想设计一种很容易被二三年级学生弄坏的乐器，那绝对是小提琴。
This is Ian Underwood. He's the guy who wrote that pamphlet. Ian's a member of the Free State Project, a movement of libertarians who, 20 years ago, started to move to New Hampshire with the goal of getting elected to local office and creating a barely-regulated, barely-taxed utopia of sorts. They're becoming a more serious political force with wins across the state. The majority leader in the House of Representatives, he moved here as a Free-Stater.
这位是伊恩·安德伍德。他就是写那份小册子的人。伊恩是“自由州计划”的一员，这是一个自由意志主义者的运动，20年前开始移居新罕布什尔，目标是当选地方官员，创造一个几乎不受监管、几乎不征税的乌托邦。他们正成为一股更严肃的政治力量，在全州范围内取得胜利。众议院多数党领袖就是作为一名“自由州成员”搬到这里的。
Ian has lived here for about 15 years on a dirt road above the Croydon schoolhouse. He thinks public school is a failure. One of the high schools down the road has really low test scores, and every year they ask for more money. So Ian, at the meeting, makes a proposal, something he'd been planning.
伊恩已经在克罗伊登校舍上方的一条土路上住了大约15年。他认为公立学校是失败的。路尽头的一所高中考试成绩很差，而且每年都要求更多的钱。所以伊恩在会议上提出了一个提案，这是他一直计划好的。
I stood up and I said, what we're being presented with is a ransom, not a budget. I think, instead, the town should present them with a budget. You have a certain amount of money and you figure out how to make it work. And so that requires us to pick a number. Let's change it from $1.7 million to $800,000. I move that that be the budget number.
我站起来说，我们面前呈现的不是预算，而是勒索。我认为，相反，镇上应该提交一份预算。你有一笔钱，然后你想办法让它运作起来。所以这就要求我们选一个数字。让我们把它从170万美元改为80万美元。我动议将此作为预算金额。
Ian was proposing cutting the budget by more than half, basically blowing up the system. Jim, who in the past had been shot down proposing much smaller cuts, knew Ian was going to do this. And he was ready.
伊恩提议将预算削减一半以上，基本上是要炸掉这个系统。过去曾因提议小额削减而被驳回的吉姆，知道伊恩会这么做。而且他准备好了。
When he made his motion, a bunch of us rushed to second it. A good four or five people jumped in to second it. There was an enthusiasm about, yes, let's do this. Let's have this discussion.
当他提出动议时，我们中的一群人冲上去附议。足足有四五个人跳出来附议。有一种热情，是的，让我们这么做吧。让我们讨论一下。
Tom Moore, the school board member with the wooden pens who has three kids in school, started to panic.
带着木笔、有三个孩子在学校上学的学校董事会成员汤姆·摩尔开始恐慌。
And that's when I started really trying to speak to the audience. And I pointed out, look, if you cut this down to $800,000, this budget just does not work. And I'm looking around the room, and I'm trying to suss out, OK, how many people here are going to shut this down. And I'm not seeing too many of them. And I'm starting to realize, boy, this could go really sideways.
那时我开始真正试图向观众喊话。我指出，看，如果你把它砍到80万美元，这个预算根本行不通。我环顾四周，试图摸清情况，好吧，这里有多少人会阻止它。但我没看到几个。我开始意识到，天哪，这可能会偏离轨道太远了。
Tom texts his wife, "Get down here, bring everyone you know." But the vote happens too fast. People raise their hands, yay or nay. The moderator counts. And the slashed budget passes, 20 to 14. The people of Croydon have spoken, the 4% of them who actually came to the meeting. Later, someone called a lawyer and a state official to see if there was any way to reverse this and learned the vote was binding.
汤姆给妻子发短信：“快来这儿，带上你知道的所有人。”但投票进行得太快。人们举手，赞成或反对。主持人清点。削减后的预算以20比14通过了。克罗伊登的民众已经表态了，是那4%真正参加会议的人。后来，有人打电话给律师和州政府官员，看看有没有办法撤回这个决定，结果得知投票具有法律约束力。
He grabbed the bottle of whiskey, poured himself a glass, and he just said, you have no idea what just happened.
他拿起那瓶威士忌，给自己倒了一杯，说，你根本不知道刚刚发生了什么。
This is Tom's wife, Jennifer. Tom's not much of a drinker, so she knew whatever happened was bad. And it was pretty bad for them.
这是汤姆的妻子詹妮弗。汤姆不怎么喝酒，所以她知道发生了什么坏事。这对他们来说确实非常糟糕。
The new school budget meant that they, and many other parents, could have to start paying to keep their kids in public school. And it was a lot of money, potentially up to $9,000 per year, per kid. That's because Croydon is so tiny, it doesn't have its own middle and high school, so older kids go to school in nearby, bigger towns. And Croydon covers that tuition.
新的学校预算意味着他们，以及许多其他家长，可能必须开始掏钱让孩子上公立学校。这是一大笔钱，每人每年可能高达9000美元。这是因为克罗伊登太小了，没有自己的初中和高中，所以大一点的孩子要去附近更大的城镇上学。克罗伊登负责这部分学费。
But with the budget cut so drastically, the town could only afford to pay half the tuition at some of those schools. So parents would have to make up the difference. For Tom and Jennifer, sending their three kids to one of the medium-priced public schools, that'd be about $20,000 a year. That's money they don't have. A lot of families here don't.
但由于预算被剧烈削减，小镇只能负担得起那些学校一半的学费。所以家长们必须自己补齐差额。对汤姆和詹妮弗来说，送三个孩子去中等价位的公立学校，那一年大约要两万美元。这笔钱他们没有。这里很多家庭也没有。
Like, we're going to have to look for another place to live, because we're not going to be able to afford sending our kids to school. I mean--
就像，我们得找别的地方住，因为我们将负担不起送孩子上学。我是说——
And that's a conversation we never thought we would ever have.
那是一个我们从未想过会有的对话。
We've never had that--
我们从没有过这种——
For Tom, this cut felt like a violation of a basic tenet of our democracy.
对汤姆来说，这次削减感觉是对我们民主基本原则的侵犯。
It baffles me. It just-- I don't understand it. I don't get it. I mean, we decided this centuries ago. I mean, we decided ages and ages ago, that this is what we should be doing as a country. We need to provide students with an adequate education through taxation.
这让我困惑。它只是——我不明白。我不懂。我的意思是，我们几个世纪前就决定了。我的意思是，我们在很久很久以前就决定了，作为国家，这就是我们应该做的事。我们需要通过税收为学生提供足够的教育。
There were some alternatives to paying to send your kid to public school. The school board said kids could enroll in a learning pod instead, managed by private companies. It'd be a mix of in-person and online learning. And it was cheap enough to fit within the slashed budget.
有一些替代方案可以不用掏钱送孩子去公立学校。学校董事会说孩子们可以转而参加一个学习小组，由私人公司管理。那将是线下和线上学习的混合。而且它便宜到足以放入被削减的预算中。
Tom says, this would be a crap show. His kids didn't do well with online learning during the pandemic. They felt distracted and isolated. Meanwhile, members of the Free State Project were going online and celebrating, saying, look at Croydon, this is how we slash taxes and transform public education. Croydon parents saw this kind of thing on Facebook and felt like, all of a sudden, their kids were part of some experiment. And they were pissed.
汤姆说，这会是一场灾难。他的孩子在疫情期间的线上学习表现不好。他们感到分心和孤立。与此同时，“自由州计划”的成员们在网上庆祝，说，看看克罗伊登，这就是我们如何削减税收和改变公共教育的方法。克罗伊登的家长们在Facebook上看到了这类东西，觉得仿佛一夜之间，他们的孩子成了某种实验品。他们气坏了。
I'm gonna to call this meeting to order at 6:31.
我宣布会议于6点31分开始。
Here's some tape from a school board meeting, post-budget cut. It's a mom talking about her son.
这是一段预算削减后的学校董事会录音。是一位母亲在谈论她的儿子。
And he's a senior next year. And if that's taken away from him after the last two years, I can't handle it. I can't do it. You cannot hurt the kids.
他明年就是高三了。如果在那过去的两年之后，他又被剥夺了这一切，我承受不住。我做不到。你们不能伤害孩子们。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
That meeting, significantly better attended. These parents had been told the budget cut was binding. But they thought, there must be some way out of this. They started calling around, going down internet rabbit holes, and looking for an escape route because democracies are never as simple as just a bunch of people voting. There's always a clause somewhere-- a guardrail for Americans against themselves. And then-- and it's not exactly clear who found it. A lot of people say it was this woman Lorraine.
那次会议的出席人数明显多了很多。家长们被告知预算削减具有约束力。但他们想，一定有办法摆脱这个困境。他们开始四处打电话，在互联网的深洞里寻找，寻找逃生路线，因为民主永远不会像一群人投票那么简单。总是会有某个条款——作为美国人防止自我伤害的护栏。然后——而且并不完全清楚是谁发现的。很多人说是这个叫洛林的女士。
But in any case, parents land on something buried deep in New Hampshire state law. RSA 197:2-- it basically says that they can petition to hold a special meeting where the town gets another chance to vote on the school budget. But it's a long shot. Not only would parents have to win the revote. The revote would only count if half of croydon's registered voters show up and cast a ballot. That's 283 people. For Tom, who used to be on the Croydon School Board, that number seemed impossible.
但无论如何，家长们发现了一些埋藏在新罕布什尔州法律深处的东西。RSA 197:2——它基本上说，他们可以请愿举行一次特别会议，让城镇有另一次机会投票决定学校预算。但这是一个难点。家长们不仅要赢得重新投票。重新投票只有在克罗伊登一半的注册选民出席并投票的情况下才算数。那是283人。对于曾经在学校董事会任职的汤姆来说，那个数字看起来不可能实现。
It's a big number. It's a very small town. We've never, ever, ever had that many people show up to vote on something.
这是一个很大的数字。这是一个非常小的城镇。我们从未，从未，从未有那么多人出来投票表决什么事。
He says the school board was lucky if five or six people came to watch. After I heard about this revote, I decided to stick around Croydon because I really could not tell what would happen, and because this seemed like a test for some big questions a lot of Americans are asking about the future of public schools and our democracy.
他说学校董事会运气好也就五六个人来旁听。在听说这个重新投票后，我决定留在克罗伊登，因为我真的看不出会发生什么，而且因为这似乎是一场测试，测试很多美国人正在提出的关于公立学校和我们民主未来的重大问题。
Slashing the school budget to $800,000 would save each household in Croydon an average of $2,000 a year. And this town leans conservative, went for Trump. A lot of people, they want lower taxes and minimal government. And the question of the school budget was not going to be decided with PAC money or TV ads, but the old fashioned way-- neighbors talking to neighbors-- people they actually know-- to try to persuade them, one by one.
将学校预算削减到80万美元，每个克罗伊登家庭平均每年可以节省2000美元。这个城镇倾向于保守，投票支持了特朗普。很多人想要更低的税收和最小化的政府。关于学校预算的问题不会由政治行动委员会的资金或电视广告来决定，而是以老派的方式——邻居对邻居交谈——那些他们真正认识的人——试图一个接一个地说服他们。
They needed 283 voters to show up in person. And they had a tight deadline, about 40 days. One thing about democracy the founding fathers forgot to tell us-- it can be a real pain in the ass. To reverse the budget cut, a group of mostly public school parents put their lives on hold. The first three weeks were an organizing frenzy-- meetings, constant Facebook messaging. They ordered lawn signs and hand-painted bigger ones that they stuck in the back of pickup trucks and put all over town.
他们需要283名选民亲自出席。他们有一个紧迫的截止日期，大约40天。关于民主，开国元勋们忘了告诉我们一件事——它真的可以是个非常麻烦的事情。为了撤销预算削减，一群大多是公立学校家长的组织把生活暂停了。前三周是组织上的狂热——会议、不断的Facebook信息。他们订购了草坪标志，手工绘制了更大的，插在皮卡车后面，贴遍全镇。
There were two moms at the center of this, sisters-- twin sisters, actually-- Angi and Amie, who I spent a lot of time with. Amie is the one you heard in that town meeting talking about her high school son. A month and a half after the meeting in March, with just one week to go before the revote, Amie and Angi are driving from house to house, trying to convince people to come to the revote. They've never done a campaign like this before.
在这项运动的核心有两位妈妈，姐妹——其实是双胞胎姐妹——安吉和艾米，我和她们待了很长时间。艾米就是你在那场镇会议上听到谈论她高中儿子的那个人。三月份会议过后一个半月，距离重新投票还有一周，艾米和安吉开车挨家挨户拜访，试图说服人们参加重新投票。她们以前从未做过这样的竞选活动。
We're bad at this. They say, we're not registered voters. OK, that's fine.
我们不擅长这个。他们说，我们不是注册选民。好的，没关系。
Angi and Amie grew up in Croydon. Their car has an American flag tinted on the back window. They've been well-liked since they were kids. In high school, Amie got voted best all-around. Angi-- most sarcastic. The Freaks, they're called. That's their family's last name.
安吉和艾米在克罗伊登长大。她们的车后窗上贴着一面美国国旗。她们从小就讨人喜欢。在高中，艾米被评为“最佳全能学生”。安吉——“最爱讽刺人”。她们被称为“怪胎”。那是她们家族的姓氏。
I kept my name. I married. My wife Cally took my name-- Freak. So we're Freaks. And everybody knows us, and they love it.
我保留了我的姓。我结婚了。我的妻子凯莉用了我的姓——怪胎。所以我们是怪胎。大家都认识我们，也喜欢这个。
Everybody knows us.
大家都认识我们。
They go to visit a guy named Brian, whose mom is there.
她们去拜访一个叫布莱恩的人，他的妈妈也在那儿。
We're going around canvassing, making sure everybody's going. You're going.
我们正在四处拉票，确保每个人都会去。你会去的。
Yes, we're going.
是的，我们会去。
So that's one yes.
那这是一个赞成票。
Brian, you're the best.
布莱恩，你最棒了。
Grandma Edie, you're going next Saturday, right? To the meeting? I love you.
埃迪奶奶，下周六你会去吧？参加会议？我爱你。
Two, actually.
其实是两个。
Is she coming?
她会来吗？
Yes.
是的。
But at another house--
但在另一家——
I wanted to.
我本来想去的。
OK.
好的。
But I have to work.
但我得工作。
OK. OK. That's OK.
好的。好的。没关系。
If there was--
如果有办法——
I'll call for you. I will call them and say, she is so busy today.
我会帮你打个电话。我会告诉他们，她今天太忙了。
If there was a way that I could vote and not be there, I would.
如果有什么办法能让我不用去现场就能投票，我会的。
Yeah.
是的。
And then they go to the house of someone they grew up with-- Nick Avery. Their kids went to school together.
然后她们去了她们一起长大的一个人——尼克·艾弗里的家。他们的孩子曾经一起上学。
We are out chatting with people about coming to the meeting on Saturday. And I know that you guys are up in the air about it.
我们正在四处聊天，关于周六去参加会议的事。我知道你们对此还在犹豫。
I'm not up in the air about it. I'm not going.
我没犹豫。我不打算去。
You're not going.
你不去。
Nope.
不去。
OK. Can you tell me why?
好的。能告诉我为什么吗？
It's just my choice.
这只是我的选择。
OK. OK.
好的。好的。
I don't want any hard feelings in this little town.
我不想在这个小镇上有什么隔阂。
Yeah. OK.
是的。好的。
Do you think-- the vote's going to make hard feelings? I still love you.
你觉得——投票会导致隔阂吗？我依然爱你。
No, I think me not going could.
不，我觉得我不去可能会。
Before they went out door knocking today, Angi and Amie got advice from a professional campaign organizer that if someone says no, just move on. Reasonable advice-- they ignore it.
今天出门敲门之前，安吉和艾米从一位专业竞选组织者那里得到了建议，如果有人拒绝，就继续前进。合理的建议——她们忽略了。
I've lived here my whole life. So have you guys.
我在这里住了一辈子。你们也是。
Yeah, absolutely.
是的，绝对。
It's honestly a little disappointing, just because I'm going to have to pay for Caleb for his senior year, you know?
说实话这有点让人失望，仅仅是因为我得为凯莱布的高中最后一年买单，你知道吗？
I get it. I get it.
我明白。我明白。
I don't think that's fair.
我不觉得这公平。
I'm not saying it's fair.
我没说这公平。
Do you think, because we didn't go vote, we weren't there at the meeting? That that's why you're--
你认为，是因为我们没去投票，我们没去参加会议？这就是为什么你——
Oh, yeah, she didn't go.
噢，是的，她没去。
I didn't go to the meeting. I got my hand slapped. I will never miss another meeting. I'll tell you what.
我没去参加会议。我受教训了。我再也不会错过任何会议了。我告诉你吧。
I'll be honest with you. $1.7 million is way too much for this town.
我实话实说。170万美元对这个镇来说太多了。
Nick starts talking about Croydon's one-room schoolhouse, still in operation, which he and the sisters went to as kids. He doesn't get why it needs so many more staff and resources these days.
尼克开始谈论克罗伊登的一间教室校舍，至今仍在运作，他和这对姐妹小时候都去过。他不明白为什么现在需要这么多额外的工作人员和资源。
You know, when we were there, we had two rows for first grade, two rows for second grade, and two rows for third grade. We had a teacher that assigned stuff, and we had--
你知道，当我们在那儿的时候，一年级两排，二年级两排，三年级两排。我们有一位老师分配作业，我们有——
An aide.
一名助手。
--and aide or two aides to help out with the kids.
——一名助手或两名助手来帮忙照看孩子。
Yeah, I remember that. We absolutely did. Now, can I--
是的，我记得。我们绝对有。现在，我可以——
You can say anything you want.
你想说什么都行。
I want to ask you a question. So $1.7 is too much. We're operating at $1.5 right now, right?
我想问你一个问题。所以170万太多了。我们现在以150万运作，对吧？
Yep.
是的。
They cannot operate what they're trying to do with $800,000.
他们没法用80万美元运作他们想做的事。
We all know that the state of New Hampshire is not going to allow kids not to go to school. Do you honestly think that, come fall, you're going to have to pay nine grand out of your pocket to send your kid to school?
我们都知道新罕布什尔州不会允许孩子不上学。你真的认为，到了秋天，你得自掏腰包掏9000块送你孩子上学吗？
Yes.
是的。
But it's a public school. They're not going to turn the kid away. They're not going to get to the school, and the principal's going to come out and go, sorry, little fellow, you got to go home because you're a Croydon kid.
但这可是公立学校。他们不会拒绝孩子入学。孩子到了学校，校长不会出来说，抱歉，小伙子，你得回家，因为你是克罗伊登的孩子。
I'm pretty sure that if we don't pay, that's what they're going to do. Do you want me to find that out for you? Do you want me to call Newport?
我相当确定如果我们不交钱，他们就会那么做。你想让我为你去查查吗？你想让我给纽波特打个电话吗？
I just-- I can't for the life of me believe--
我只是——我无论如何都不敢相信——
This is what I'm going to do. Just so we can continue this conversation, I'm going to call the Department of Revenue tomorrow and speak with a representative there. And I meant to ask them this this past week, actually. So I'm glad that you brought this up.
这就是我打算做的。为了继续我们的对话，我明天要给税务局打电话，跟那里的代表谈谈。其实上周我就想问他们这个问题。所以我很高兴你提到了这一点。
But the other problem is, people around here have watched that budget go up and up and up and up.
但另一个问题是，这里的人们看着那个预算涨啊涨啊，一直涨。
Right.
没错。
And nobody's really said much till now. And now everybody's crying wolf.
直到现在都没人真正说什么。现在大家都在喊“狼来了”。
Listen, if they had cut it by $200,000, this would not be happening. Honestly, a $200,000 cut would not change-- there's a turkey right there. [LAUGHS] Did you go out this morning?
听着，如果他们砍掉20万美元，这事儿就不会发生了。说实话，砍掉20万美元不会改变——那里有一只火鸡。[笑] 你今天早上出去了吗？
May in New Hampshire is wild turkey hunting season. By the end, the sisters have spent 30 minutes with Nick. It doesn't move them any closer to their magic number of 283 voters. But it's something you don't see much these days-- people who don't agree actually talking to each other and listening. And it was nice to hear.
五月在新罕布什尔是野生火鸡狩猎季。最后，姐妹俩和尼克聊了30分钟。这并没有让她们更接近283名选民的魔法数字。但这是一种你现在很少见到的场景——意见不同的人确实在交谈并倾听对方。这听起来很不错。
Thank you, Nick. Sorry to interrupt your work.
谢谢你，尼克。抱歉打断你的工作。
It's all right. Next time, I'll put you to work.
没事。下次，我让你帮我干活。
She said!
她说得对！
By the way, Angi and other parents did talk to neighboring school districts about whether they'd let in Croydon students for half price. And they were basically told, no way. Meanwhile, the other side has a way easier campaign ahead of them because the only thing the budget cutters need people to do is nothing-- just skip the meeting.
顺便说一句，安吉和其他家长确实和邻近的学区谈过是否愿意半价接收克罗伊登的学生。基本上都被告知没门。与此同时，另一方有一场轻松得多的竞选，因为预算削减者只需要人们做一件事，就是什么都不做——只要别去参加会议就行。
That way, the revote won't meet quorum, and it won't count. To reinforce this message, the man who proposed the budget cut back in March sends out mailers. They say, "If you like the budget you have, you can keep it. Just stay home on May 7." Jim Paschke, the budget nerd who'd been trying to cut the budget for years, is feeling pretty confident.
这样，重新投票就不会达到法定人数，也就无效了。为了加强这一信息，三月份提议削减预算的人发出了邮件。他们说：“如果你喜欢你现在的预算，你可以保留它。5月7日呆在家里就行。”一直试图削减预算的预算书呆子吉姆·佩什克感到非常自信。
I think there's a false narrative that a bunch of kooks voted for this budget, and the whole town is against it. I don't think that's true. And the problem with getting people to go is there's only a handful of people in Croydon who truly benefit from the higher budget.
我认为存在一种虚假的叙事，说一群疯子投票支持这个预算，而整个镇都反对它。我不认为这是真的。而且说服人们参加的问题在于，克罗伊登只有少数几个人真正从高预算中受益。
The way he sees the math, there are only 80 or so kids in the school district. So sure, their families will show up to restore the budget. But he doesn't think they'll get enough of their neighbors to join them.
按照他的数学逻辑，学区里只有大约80个孩子。所以当然，他们的家庭会出来恢复预算。但他认为他们无法说服足够的邻居加入他们。
--the numbers and the updated calling list. Tomorrow, I know we've got the--
——数字和更新的电话名单。明天，我知道我们有——
It's Wednesday, May 4, three days till the revote. Some of the parents organizing, who call themselves We Stand Up For Croydon, gather in private-- start tallying up the confirmed numbers. They want to know how close they are to 283.
5月4日星期三，距离重新投票还有三天。一些组织活动的家长，自称“我们为克罗伊登站出来”，私下聚集在一起——开始汇总确认的数字。他们想知道离283人还差多少。
Zandra, do you want to talk a little bit about our updated list?
桑德拉，你想谈谈我们更新的名单吗？
We look at 275 supporters ID'ed so far-- 236 who can attend. So that's a big drop off.
我们目前确认了275名支持者——236人可以参加。所以有很大的流失。
That's terrible.
太糟糕了。
That's Angi saying it's terrible. They need about 50 more. The next day is the final push-- the phone bank.
那是安吉在说太糟糕了。他们还需要50人左右。第二天是最后的冲刺——电话拉票。
Can we call Brenda and Roderick and just confirm? I have called, texted, and Facebook messaged Brad with no response.
我们可以打给布伦达和罗德里克确认一下吗？我给布拉德打过电话、发过短信和Facebook消息，但没回复。
Angi's here in her go-to outfit-- t-shirt, jeans, eyeliner, and mascara. There's not good cell phone service in Croydon. So the volunteers have gone to a nearby town, ordered pizza. They have a big list of names, and they start making calls. Angi's focused. She rubs her temples a lot. There's a problem with the list of names.
安吉穿着她标志性的服装——T恤、牛仔裤、眼线和睫毛膏。克罗伊登的手机信号不好。所以志愿者们去了附近的一个城镇，点了披萨。他们有一长串名字，开始打电话。安吉很专注。她经常揉太阳穴。名单有问题。
Well, the tricky thing is we don't know if there's duplicates.
嗯，棘手的是我们不知道有没有重复的人。
The majority of volunteers here are-- surprise, surprise-- moms. Most have jobs and kids who are currently in school. They've disagreed on some things in the past like mask mandates. But when it comes to funding public schools, they're all on the same page.
这里的志愿者大多是——出人意料——妈妈们。大多数人有工作，孩子正在上学。过去她们在一些事情上有分歧，比如口罩强制令。但当涉及到公立学校经费时，她们都在同一阵线上。
Is there any way I might--
有没有什么办法我可能——
One of them is Amanda Leslie, mom of two, English teacher, who also grew up here. Usually when she and I talk about the budget cut, she uses a lot of colorful language. But when she gets on the phone, she puts on her teacher hat. She calls a family she's known for years.
其中之一是阿曼达·莱斯利，两个孩子的母亲，英语老师，也是在这儿长大的。通常我和她讨论预算削减时，她会用很多激烈的语言。但当她打电话时，她戴上了教师的帽子。她给一个认识多年的家庭打了电话。
Can I tell you a little bit of new information? No? OK. Would Ed be willing to talk with me since he will be there? Super-- that'd be great. Hey, Ed, how are you doing? Good. I understand you're going to help out at the meeting on Saturday as a ballot clerk. Can I ask, are you going to also vote while you're there? You're not going to vote? Oh, I'm so disappointed.
能告诉你一点新信息吗？不行？好的。那艾德愿意和我谈谈吗，因为他那天会在那儿？太好了——那太棒了。嘿，艾德，你好吗？好的。我知道周六你会作为投票员在会上帮忙。我可以问一下，你在那儿的时候会投票吗？你不打算投票？噢，我太失望了。
Right, but even though it's a legal thing-- I hear you. I absolutely hear that. You know, I was there too. It certainly was legal. But there is this opportunity within the democratic process to revisit it. And, I mean, do you think you could tell me that you'll think about it? OK. Well, again, I'm disappointed. But thank you for talking with me, Ed. All right, I'll see you Saturday.
没错，尽管这是合法的——我听到了。我完全听到了。你知道，我当时也在那儿。那当然合法。但民主进程中确实有这样一个重新审视的机会。而且，我是说，你觉得你能告诉我你会考虑一下吗？好的。好吧，再一次，我很失望。但谢谢你跟我谈话，艾德。好的，周六见。
Ugh. Break my fricking heart.
呃。简直伤透了我的心。
My producer, Chris, is with Amanda when she ends the call with Ed.
我的制片人克里斯在阿曼达结束与艾德的通话时和她在一起。
Is it easier or harder when you know them?
当你认识他们时，这更容易还是更难？
I think it's more heartbreaking, you know? These people that I've known the entire time I've lived in Croydon-- and my in-laws-- they've known them for 40, 50, 60 years, you know? And it's just really sad, especially because I know that they're good people. They're not total a-holes, you know?
我觉得更心碎，你知道吗？这些人我住在这个镇上一直都认识——还有我的姻亲——他们认识他们40、50、60年了，你知道吗？这真的很悲伤，尤其是因为我知道他们是好人。他们不是混蛋，你知道吗？
The guy Amanda was on the phone with-- Ed-- he had concerns I've heard from other people in town. They don't think the May 7th revote is fair. The town already made its decision in March. If people wanted to be part of the budget process and ensure their kids' school got funded, why didn't they show up then?
阿曼达通话的那个人——艾德——他有我从镇上其他人那里听到过的担忧。他们认为5月7日的重新投票不公平。小镇三月份已经做出了决定。如果人们想参与预算进程并确保他们孩子的学校得到资助，为什么那时候不去？
May 6th, the evening before the revote. The parents just finished setting up the space-- a YMCA camp, which is the biggest venue in the area they could find. The Croydon town hall couldn't fit 283 people. Angi is in the parking lot, headed to her SUV. She has a new concern. She just heard that her opponents want to make a presentation before the vote.
5月6日，重新投票的前一天晚上。家长们刚布置完场地——一个YMCA营地，这是他们能找到的附近最大的场地。克罗伊登市政厅装不下283人。安吉在停车场，走向她的SUV。她有一个新的担忧。她刚听说对手想在投票前做一个演讲。
Wait, so when did you guys find out that Aaron is giving a presentation?
等一下，你们什么时候发现亚伦要进行演讲的？
Today, tonight, here-- just found out. The moderator is who let us know.
今天，今晚，在这儿——刚发现的。是主持人告诉我们的。
This presentation is totally allowed. But Angi wonders if it's a tactic to run the clock so people will leave before the vote.
这个演讲是完全允许的。但安吉怀疑这是一种拖延时间的策略，这样人们在投票前就会离开。
Because at what point are you worried that people are going to start leaving?
因为在什么时间点你担心人们会开始离开？
Probably an hour or an hour and a half in, I think that people will start losing interest. And, I mean, they have other things to do-- legit other things to do. We have people that have funerals in Scutney, Vermont. We have people that have weddings. We have people that have college graduation in Keene. I mean, we can't ask them to sit here for hours and hours.
可能一小时或一小时半之后，我觉得人们会开始失去兴趣。而且，我是说，他们还有别的事要做——确实还有别的事要做。我们有人要在佛蒙特州的斯卡特尼参加葬礼。我们有人要参加婚礼。我们有人要在基恩参加大学毕业典礼。我的意思是，我们不能要求他们在这里坐上几个小时又几个小时。
Angi's also a bit frustrated because some people don't have plans but are like, I don't know if I can find two hours to spare to come. And Angie feels she and other moms have been working nonstop to save Croydon's public school system. Angi's accumulated stress-- it reached a breaking point when she and some volunteers were setting up today.
安吉也有些沮丧，因为有些人没什么计划，却说：“我不知道能不能抽出两小时来。”而安吉觉得她和其他妈妈们一直在不间断地努力拯救克罗伊登的公立学校系统。安吉积累的压力——当她和一些志愿者今天布置场地时，达到了崩溃点。
And so I had a minor meltdown.
所以我也经历了一次轻微的崩溃。
What did that look like?
那看起来是什么样的？
No tears. Some frustration-- enough so that people thought I needed a hug.
没有眼泪。有些挫败感——足以让人们认为我需要一个拥抱。
Wait, what did you say?
等一下，你说了什么？
Well, my sister said, what do you need from us right now? I said, I need everyone to shut the fuck up. That's what I said, if you want to be frank about it.
嗯，我妹妹说，你现在需要我们做什么？我说，我需要每个人都闭上臭嘴。这就是我说的，如果你想坦诚点的话。
Angi's not sleeping great. I'll send her a text in the middle of the day-- get a response at 3:00 AM the next morning. Angi tells me she's still feeling optimistic. But no one knows how tomorrow will play out. Here's Jennifer, Tom's wife. She tells me she's not sure it's going to work.
安吉睡得不太好。我会在白天给她发短信——第二天凌晨3点才收到回复。安吉告诉我她依然感到乐观。但没人知道明天会怎样。这是詹妮弗，汤姆的妻子。她告诉我她不确定这是否会奏效。
I think it's going to be so close. I think it's going to be within a vote or two. And that's why we so desperately are reaching out to anyone we can. And it could go either way, honestly.
我觉得会非常接近。我觉得会只差一两票。这就是为什么我们拼命地联系我们能联系到的任何人。老实说，情况可能向任何一方倾斜。
Her husband Tom feels the same. The other side seems much more relaxed.
她的丈夫汤姆感觉也一样。另一方似乎轻松得多。
I'm going turkey hunting.
我要去打猎火鸡。
This is Jim Peschke, talking about what he's going to do tomorrow during the revote. He's come up with a metaphor. I've heard it before at a school board meeting.
这是吉姆·佩什克，谈论他明天重新投票期间要做的事。他想出了一个隐喻。我以前在学校董事会会议上听过。
And if you're not familiar, I'll be sitting there with a call, trying to trick the turkeys into coming towards me under the promise of finding a hen. And I can only speak from theory because I have yet to take one. I'm a lousy turkey hunter. But I think we're going to both be coming home empty-handed on the 7th.
如果你不熟悉，我会坐在那儿用叫声，试图诱骗火鸡朝我走来，承诺能找到一只母火鸡。而且我只能从理论上说，因为我还没抓到一只。我是个蹩脚的火鸡猎人。但我认为我们俩在7号都会空手而归。
Get it? He won't get a turkey, and the parents won't get their big budget back. Finally, the day of the vote-- May 7. Voters are lined up at the registration table by 8:00 AM. It's cold. There's no heating in the hall, but there's a fireplace roaring at one end.
明白了吗？他抓不到火鸡，家长们也找不回他们的大预算。终于，投票日到了——5月7日。选民们在早上8点前就在登记台排起了长队。天气很冷。大厅里没有暖气，但一端有一堆熊熊燃烧的壁炉。
For every democratic process, there are rules and often a public official responsible for enforcing them. Here, it's the moderator-- a man named Bruce Jasper. Today is his first time moderating a town meeting. And if Angi were hoping this would go quickly, it's not looking good.
对于每一个民主进程，都有规则，通常还有负责执行规则的公职人员。这里，是主持人——一个叫布鲁斯·贾斯珀的人。今天是第一次主持镇会议。如果安吉希望这能快点进行，情况看起来不妙。
So, just a little bit about me-- I was born in Nashua, New Hampshire. I'm the oldest of four children brought up on a poultry farm. My first job was a paper route delivering, the Nashua Telegraph on my bicycle.
所以，讲讲我自己——我出生在新罕布什尔州的纳舒厄。我是四个在养鸡场长大的孩子中的老大。我的第一份工作是在自行车上送《纳舒厄电讯报》。
To be clear, he's not trying to run down the clock. He just seems really into being the moderator. He gives the number of chickens on his childhood farm, the number of people in his graduating high school class.
说明一下，他不是想故意拖延时间。他只是看起来真的很享受做主持人。他讲了小时候农场里的鸡的数量，他高中毕业班的人数。
Currently, I'm a member of the Newport Rotary Club, where I've been secretary for the last 38 years and also on the board of Wags and Wiggles, a dog rescue organization in Newport.
目前，我是纽波特扶轮社的成员，过去38年里一直担任秘书，也是纽波特一家叫“摇尾巴”的狗救援组织的董事会成员。
At first, people figure, maybe Bruce is stalling to give stragglers time to find their seats. But pretty soon, it's 9:20 AM. And people are getting antsy-- glancing at each other. Wait, this is the school budget revote, right? Bruce eventually transitions from his biography to the rules for the proceedings. He loves a good rule.
起初，人们觉得，也许布鲁斯在拖延给迟到者时间找座位。但很快，到了上午9点20分。人们开始不耐烦了——互相斜视。等等，这是学校预算重新投票，对吧？布鲁斯最终从他的传记过渡到了会议规则。他喜欢好规则。
The articles to be considered-- yep, I am. I am reading all of the rules so that everybody-- I don't know. I mean, if everybody has a copy of the rules and everybody is-- OK, I will stop here.
要审议的条款——是的，我是。我在宣读所有的规则，以便每个人——我不知道。我是说，如果每个人都有一份规则副本，每个人都——好的，我在这里停下。
Someone eventually shouts out, move on! Angi and Tom give their presentation, and then--
有人最终喊道，继续！安吉和汤姆做了他们的演讲，然后——
We have two student speakers that have very brief statements that they would like to make if we can have them come up and as long as no one opposes.
我们有两位学生发言人，如果没人反对，且我们能让他们上台，他们有非常简短的声明想说。
OK. And again, I'm--
好的。再说明一下，我——
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
The request is supposed to come through the moderator, all right? Again, it's in the rules. And I know everybody said they read it, and they all know them.
要求应该通过主持人提出，好吗？再说一次，规则里有。我知道每个人都说他们读过了，他们都知道。
Tell me what you need me to do, Bruce. I am asking you to please allow the student speakers to be a part of our presentation.
告诉我你需要我怎么做，布鲁斯。我请求你允许学生发言人作为我们演讲的一部分。
The procedure would be to ask the moderator to allow somebody to speak.
程序应该是请求主持人允许某人发言。
Will you allow them to speak?
你允许他们发言吗？
So, Angi, yes, if you're asking me, can we allow the--
所以，安吉，是的，如果你问我，我们能允许——
Bruce, may I please have a student speaker speak right now during our presentation?
布鲁斯，请允许学生发言人现在在我们的演讲中发言好吗？
And the answer is, yes, if it's informational. So my ruling is yes.
答案是，是的，如果那是为了提供信息。所以我的裁定是肯定的。
Thank you.
谢谢。
The two high schoolers, one after another, deliver their speeches. Parents had this plan a while ago. Let the kids have their say. It's about their future. But sticking to it is kind of surprising, given how anxious they are about time. I find Angi's sister, Amie, near the breakfast buffet.
两名高中生，一个接一个地发表了演讲。家长们很早之前就有这个计划。让孩子们有发言权。这是关于他们的未来。但坚持这个计划有点令人惊讶，考虑到他们对时间的焦虑。我在早餐自助餐附近找到了安吉的妹妹艾米。
I'm preparing to take--
我准备选修——
Is this going how you had hoped?
进展和你希望的一样吗？
--college classes along with advanced literature and pre-calculus.
——大学课程以及高级文学和微积分预科。
Not really. I already wanted to be in line to vote.
并不是。我早就想去排队投票了。
What time is it right now?
现在几点了？
9:35. 9:35.
9点35分。9点35分。
When are people going to start leaving?
人们什么时候会开始离开？
I play two varsity sports, volleyball and softball--
我参加两项校队运动，排球和垒球——
10:00.
10点。
--again, learning teamwork and dedication.
——同样，学习团队合作和奉献。
Yes.
是的。
And I hope to obtain scholarships--
而且我希望能获得奖学金——
What do' you think is going through Angi's head right now?
你觉得安吉现在脑子里在想什么？
Hurry the fuck up.
他妈的快点。
--opportunities which this budget cut puts in jeopardy.
——这些机会，而这次预算削减危及了这一切。
What's going through your head?
你脑子里在想什么？
The same thing. I love all these kids. But let's just do this. We all know why we're here. We don't need a boost. We all know.
同一件事。我爱所有这些孩子。但让我们快点吧。我们都知道为什么来这儿。我们不需要催促。我们都知道。
I implore you to support me in having the same opportunities that many of you had.
我恳求你们支持我，让我拥有你们许多人拥有的同样机会。
A bit later, the other side-- the people who want to stick with the budget cut-- makes their presentation. It's pretty short-- 15 minutes. Toward the end, people applaud early to try to usher the guy off stage.
过了一会儿，另一方——那些想坚持预算削减的人——进行了他们的演讲。很短——15分钟。临近结束时，人们提前鼓掌试图把那个人赶下台。
With that, I will wrap up. And I do have hard copies of this presentation if anybody wants to help circulate these.
到此为止，我结束了。如果有人想传阅，我确实有这份演讲的纸质复印件。
All right, come on. Come on. Come on. Come on.
好了，快点。快点。快点。快点。
I appreciate it, Bruce.
我领会了，布鲁斯。
And finally, 70 minutes in, it's time to vote. People form a long line to put their ballots in the box. It's the OG Croydon ballot box, by the way-- wooden, from the 1890s. Angi's standing in shock, taking this all in. And guess who she sees? Nick Avery, the guy who she and Amie spent half an hour talking with during their door knocking.
终于，70分钟过去了，投票时间到了。人们排成长队把选票放入投票箱。顺便说一句，那是克罗伊登的原版投票箱——木制的，1890年代的。安吉震惊地站在那里，观察着这一切。猜猜她看到了谁？尼克·艾弗里，那个她和艾米敲门时聊了半小时的人。
Yes, Nick and his wife and his daughter, who registered today, are here.
是的，尼克和他妻子，还有今天注册的女儿，都在这儿。
Whoa. Were you expecting that?
哇。你预料到这一点了吗？
Absolutely not. Absolutely not. I'm amazed that they came. I feel like the Grinch. My heart has grown three sizes today, Sarah.
绝对没有。绝对没有。我很惊讶他们来了。我觉得自己像那个格林奇。今天我的心长大了三倍，萨拉。
All right, I'm seeing nobody else in line that is ready to vote. The voting is now closed.
好了，我看到排队的人里没人准备投票了。投票现在结束。
The room starts clearing out quick. Volunteer clerks begin counting votes. Tom is giddy.
房间迅速清空。志愿者计票员开始数票。汤姆高兴极了。
Oh, here we go! Here we go! Easy, Ang. Easy, Ang! What's up?
噢，开始啦！开始啦！别急，安吉。别急，安吉！怎么了？
Angi comes up to him. There's a problem.
安吉走到他身边。出了问题。
He said we have too many votes. He said we have too many votes.
他说票数太多了。他说我们的票数太多了。
What do you mean we have too many votes?
什么叫票数太多了？
I don't know.
我不知道。
What does that mean?
那是什么意思？
I don't know.
我不知道。
That doesn't make any sense.
那完全说不通。
The total number of votes appears to be six more than the number of people who checked in at the door and received ballots. Some people start wondering, was it a counting problem or something sneakier? Maybe the other side slipped in some extra ballots to invalidate the vote.
总票数似乎比门口登记领取选票的人数多了六张。有些人开始怀疑，这是统计问题还是更卑鄙的事情？也许另一方塞进了额外的选票来作废投票。
Was that their trick? Are you fucking kidding me?
那是他们的诡计吗？你们在开什么他妈的玩笑吗？
I don't want people to think that this isn't legitimate. They're going to get on Facebook and say, oh, they cheated.
我不希望人们认为这不是合法的。他们会到Facebook上说，噢，他们作弊了。
But I don't know what the moderator is going to rule. He may rule we have to vote again. And if that's the case, we don't have 283 people here anymore.
但我不知道主持人会怎么裁定。他可能裁定我们要重新投票。如果是那样，我们就没有283人在现场了。
In case anyone needed another reminder that democracy is unpredictable, here we are. The voters who cast their ballots-- some of them have left. And if there's a redo today, it definitely won't make quorum. Meanwhile, the moderator, Bruce, is on the phone with someone from the New Hampshire Secretary of State's office.
如果有人还需要提醒民主是不可预测的，我们现在就是。投了票的选民——有些人已经离开了。如果今天要重来一次，肯定达不到法定人数。与此同时，主持人布鲁斯正在和新罕布什尔州州务卿办公室的人通电话。
Oh my god. I think we might have lost it because of this.
噢，天哪。我觉得我们可能因为这个输了。
And then, finally, Bruce is back at the mic.
然后，最终，布鲁斯回到了麦克风前。
We had a little discrepancy between the number of ballots cast and the number of people that checked in-- voters that checked in. However, that's now been rectified. So the final vote was 377 yes--
我们之前的投票数和登记选民数之间有一点差异。不过，现在已经修正了。所以最终投票是赞成377票——
[CHEERING]
[欢呼]
--and two no.
——反对2票。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼]
They got what they needed and nearly 100 more. Someone just counted wrong the first time. It's a landslide.
他们得到了需要的票数，还多了近100票。有人第一次数错了。这是一场压倒性的胜利。
I take a motion to adjourn.
我提议休会。
Mr. Moderator moves to adjourn.
主持先生动议休会。
Second?
附议？
Second!
附议！
All those in favor--
所有赞成的——
Aye!
赞成！
Thank you so much.
非常感谢。
Thank you so much! Oh my god!
非常感谢！噢，天哪！
Thank you so much.
非常感谢。
People are hugging and high-fiving. Angi reaches out to shake hands with a guy she's known for years. They messed with the wrong town, he tells her. They, meaning the budget cutters and the libertarians who championed this. Just a few of them are here, and they don't look happy. We called up Jim Peschke, the guy who spent the morning turkey hunting. He didn't catch one. Here's what he said about the revote.
人们在拥抱和击掌。安吉伸出手去和一位认识多年的家伙握手。他告诉她，他们惹错了镇子。他们，指那些预算削减者和支持这一点的自由意志主义者。他们中只有几个人在这儿，看起来很不高兴。我们打电话给了吉姆·佩什克，那个早上花时间去打火鸡的人。他一只没抓到。这是他关于重新投票的评价。
It was a very well-run, very effective campaign on their part. I know they did a lot of work. And they were able to get their message through, which I found very surprising.
这是他们组织的非常出色、非常有效的竞选。我知道他们做了很多工作。他们能够传达他们的信息，这让我非常惊讶。
So he accepts the results even though he doesn't agree with them, which, in 2022, is not always something you can count on. And some of the budget cutters-- they're not done. They lost the battle this year but aren't abandoning their mission. Many parents told me that this scare-- it woke them up.
所以他接受了结果，尽管他不同意，在2022年，这并不总是可以指望的事情。而且一些预算削减者——他们还没完。他们今年输了，但并没有放弃使命。许多家长告诉我，这次恐吓——它唤醒了他们。
They're continuing to organize, run for office, and show up to meetings. A few days later, the Croydon School Board met. A lot of people came out. And frankly, it was uneventful-- long, tedious. And sitting there, I wondered whether people will keep showing up year after year when there isn't a crisis because, ultimately, how much time are most of us willing to give to democracy?
他们继续组织活动，竞选公职，并出现在会议上。几天后，克罗伊登学校董事会开会。很多人出来了。老实说，没发生什么——又长又乏味。坐在那儿，我想知道，当没有危机时，人们还会年复一年地出现吗？因为最终，我们大多数人愿意为民主贡献多少时间？
Sarah Gibson of New Hampshire Public Radio-- that story was produced by Chris Benderev. Coming up, murderous snails tear through an island, leaving a trail of carnage. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
新罕布什尔州公共广播电台的萨拉·吉布森——那个故事由克里斯·本德雷夫制作。接下来，食肉蜗牛撕裂了一个岛屿，留下一片狼藉。芝加哥公共广播电台节目继续。
It's This American Life-- I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "I Work Better on Deadline"-- stories of how deadlines can release an explosion of energy from people who never would have taken action any other way to fix problems that probably should have been addressed long before.
这里是《美国生活》——我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“我在最后期限下工作更好”——讲述人们如何因最后期限释放出爆炸性的能量，这些人们在任何其他情况下都不会采取行动去修复那些本应早该处理的问题。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Snail in the Coffin. So I think of myself as a not terribly industrious person who happens to have organized his life around a very unforgiving weekly deadline. And really, only because of the deadline, I'm filled with enough terror to finish stories and get a radio show on the air with a coherent beginning, middle, and ending to it, week after week, with a team of people.
我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，棺材里的蜗牛。所以我认为自己不是一个非常勤奋的人，只是碰巧把生活安排在了一个非常不留情面的每周截止日期周围。说真的，只有因为这个截止日期，我才充满了足够的恐惧去完成故事，并让一个有连贯的开头、中间和结尾的广播节目每周播出，带着一群人。
Without the deadline, I really would never be anywhere as productive. But the stakes of this whole thing are really pretty low, right? If I and my coworkers don't turn out a new show, so what? One less radio episode in the world. Nobody suffers. Nothing dies. The world continues as it was. Not so for the people in this next story. David Kestenbaum explains.
没有截止日期，我真的永远不会像现在这样有效率。但这一切的利害关系其实相当低，对吧？如果我和我的同事没有做出新节目，那又怎样？世界上少了一集广播节目。没人受苦。什么也没死。世界依旧运转。但这对于下一个故事里的人们来说并非如此。大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆解释说。
This is a terrible way to start a story, but it's a fact. I've been kind of obsessed with extinctions recently. Sure, the dinosaurs because who doesn't like a good asteroid extinction? Or maybe it was a comet. There's also the Permian mass extinction, which wiped out over 80% of stuff in the sea-- totally fascinating. I think I'm interested because of this idea that now we may be living through another mass extinction-- one we are causing.
这是一个开始故事的糟糕方式，但这是一个事实。我最近一直有点迷恋灭绝。当然，恐龙，因为谁不喜欢好的小行星灭绝呢？或者也许是彗星。还有二叠纪大灭绝，它抹去了海里80%多的生物——非常迷人。我想我是因为这个想法感兴趣，即现在我们可能正在经历另一次大灭绝——一个我们造成的灭绝。
According to the international organization that tracks this stuff, one in eight bird species are threatened. 1/5 of all reptiles, 1/4 of all mammals, and plants-- 40% of all plant species could disappear. 40%-- it's hard to get your head around that. But I sort of feel like I should. Even before this, I did this thing. I regularly tried to imagine my parents' deaths, just to be prepared-- and my own death, which is a kind of personal extinction. It's a way of getting used to the idea of things ending. You can also try to imagine the extinction of democracy. See? It's a fun game.
根据追踪这些东西的国际组织，八分之一的鸟类受到威胁。五分之一的爬行动物，四分之一的哺乳动物，还有植物——40%的所有植物物种可能消失。40%——很难让人理解这个数字。但我有点觉得我应该理解。甚至在此之前，我就做过这件事。我经常试着想象我父母的死亡，只是为了做好准备——以及我自己的死亡，这是一种个人的灭绝。这是一种习惯接受事物终结的想法的方法。你也可以试着想象民主的灭绝。看？这是一个有趣的游戏。
This, of course, is an entirely theoretical exercise on my part. But there are people who actually stare into the abyss of it-- of the things facing extinction-- and try to do something. In talking to people, I found this one story I think has never really been told. It's about a snail-- one single species of all these in trouble-- and this chain of really ingenious people who are determined to save it. The story starts with Justin Gerlach, who now is a fellow at Cambridge University. But, in 1992, he was a grad student standing on the island of Raiatea in the middle of the Pacific-- lush tropical place with cliffs-- looking for this snail-- kind of famous in snail circles. It's fancy name-- partula faba.
当然，这完全是我个人的理论练习。但有些人确实凝视着它的深渊——那些面临灭绝的事物——并试图做点什么。在与人们交谈时，我发现了一个我认为从未真正被讲述过的故事。它是关于一只蜗牛的——所有这些陷入困境的物种中的一个单一物种——以及这一群决心拯救它的充满创意的人。故事始于贾斯汀·格拉赫，他现在是剑桥大学的研究员。但是，1992年，他是一名研究生，站在太平洋中部赖阿特亚岛上——郁郁葱葱的热带地方，有悬崖——寻找这只蜗牛——在蜗牛圈里有点出名。它花哨的名字——partula faba。
I call it Captain Cook's bean snail.
我叫它库克船长的豆蜗牛。
How come?
为什么？
Because it was discovered on Captain Cook's expedition. And faba means bean.
因为它是在库克船长的探险中发现的。而faba意思是豆子。
Did he call it that?
他管它叫那个名字吗？
No. No, he didn't call it anything.
不。不，他什么也没叫。
Sadly but not surprisingly, he says, Captain Cook never wrote anything in his diaries about the snail. It was named afterward. Scientists ended up learning a lot about genetics from partula snails years later. This one-- particularly kind of dignified as snails go-- about an inch long.
遗憾但并不令人惊讶的是，他说，库克船长在日记里从未写过关于这只蜗牛的任何事情。它是后来命名的。科学家们多年后最终从帕图拉蜗牛那里学到了很多关于遗传学的知识。这一只——在蜗牛中显得相当庄重——大约一英寸长。
So it's a really nice looking shell. It's the most beautiful of the partula species-- very nice deep yellow color with a dark tip to the shell. And sometimes, they've got dark bands on them as well-- really handsome snail.
所以它是一个非常漂亮的壳。它是帕图拉物种中最漂亮的一种——非常漂亮的深黄色，壳尖是深色的。有时它们身上还有深色条纹——非常漂亮的蜗牛。
The snail, when Justin got to the island, was in trouble-- because of us. Justin told me the story with a kind of professorial calm. He's had a front row seat to species extinction for a while now. What happened, he says, is that, at some point, a different snail had been brought to the island-- the giant African land snail-- basically a garden pest, he says. It got out of control. And the solution to that problem was to introduce another snail-- a predatory one that people hoped would eat the African land snail.
当贾斯汀到达岛上时，蜗牛陷入了困境——因为我们。贾斯汀带着一种教授式的冷静讲述了这个故事。他有一段时间一直坐在物种灭绝的第一线。他说，发生的事情是，在某个时候，另一种蜗牛被带到了岛上——大非洲陆地蜗牛——基本上是一种园艺害虫，他说。它失控了。解决那个问题的办法是引入另一种蜗牛——一种捕食性的蜗牛，人们希望它会吃掉非洲陆地蜗牛。
It's kind of crazy that they had one out-of-control control snail, so they introduced a second snail--
他们有一种失控的控制蜗牛，所以他们引入了第二种蜗牛——
Yep.
是的。
--to eat the first snail.
——去吃掉第一种蜗牛。
Yep.
是的。
Maybe you can see where this is going. The new snail had no interest in this assignment.
也许你能看出这要走向何方。新来的蜗牛对这项任务毫无兴趣。
Basically, it didn't like the giant African snail. They're too big. They're too leathery. So it doesn't eat them. It likes the little forest snails instead.
基本上，它不喜欢大非洲蜗牛。它们太大了。它们太像皮革了。所以它不吃它们。它反而喜欢小森林蜗牛。
Including Captain Cook's bean snail. Climate change, for sure, is putting a lot of species in danger. But most creatures on the endangered list-- they're there for reasons like this-- much more basic stuff. We cut down some forest to farm or build homes. We catch too many fish. Or we bring some foreign snail to an island. So Justin's on the island to rescue any survivors he can find. He heads out and gets to this one valley where the invading snails had apparently just swept through, maybe a week before.
包括库克船长的豆蜗牛。气候变化确实让很多物种处于危险之中。但濒危名单上的大多数生物——它们出现在那里是因为这样的原因——更基本的东西。我们砍掉一些森林来耕种或盖房。我们捕捞过多的鱼。或者我们带一些外来蜗牛到岛上。所以贾斯汀在岛上营救他能找到的幸存者。他出发并到达了这个山谷，入侵的蜗牛显然就在一周前刚刚席卷过这里。
And it was just completely littered with hundreds of empty shells. And some of them were still damp from where they'd been eaten by the predatory snails.
那里完全满地都是数百个空壳。其中一些甚至还是湿的，就是它们被捕食性蜗牛吃掉的地方。
He had this thought.
他有了这个念头。
Maybe, actually, I've been too late-- just that little bit too late.
也许，事实上，我来晚了——仅仅是晚了那么一点点。
There's like a massacre or something.
这就像是一场屠杀什么的。
Yeah, very much a massacre-- a slow-motion massacre but, nonetheless--
是的，非常像屠杀——一场慢动作的屠杀，但尽管如此——
That's snails are slow-- joke number one for this story. There'll be another.
蜗牛很慢——这个故事的第一个笑话。还会有另一个。
How can they be so good at killing every last snail?
它们怎么能如此擅长杀掉每一只蜗牛？
They're extremely efficient predators. So they're very good at picking up the chemical cues left behind by the slime trails. So they track them down like a bloodhound, essentially. And then they're very good, perfectly evolved killing machines, really.
它们是非常有效的捕食者。它们非常擅长捕捉粘液痕迹留下的化学信号。所以它们基本上像猎犬一样追踪它们。然后它们是非常完美进化的杀戮机器，真的。
If it seems hard to imagine how an animal with no arms or hands or claws or talons, whose name is appropriately synonymous with slowness, can kill anything at all, I found a video online. It's gruesome. The predatory snail just kind of sucks the other snail out of its shell while it struggles to fight back. Justin does find one-- one bean snail in that valley. He puts it in a plastic container. And then a piece of luck-- he finds an old vanilla plantation the predatory snails hadn't reached yet. And there are dozens of bean snails.
如果很难想象一只没有手臂、手、爪子或指甲的动物，名字恰当地与缓慢同义，竟然能杀掉任何东西，我在网上找到了一个视频。它非常恐怖。捕食性蜗牛只是把另一只蜗牛从壳里吸出来，同时它挣扎反抗。贾斯汀在那山谷里找到了一只——一只豆蜗牛。他把它放进一个塑料容器里。然后运气来了——他发现了一个古老的香草种植园，捕食性蜗牛还没到达那里。那里有几十只豆蜗牛。
You got there just in time.
你及时赶到了。
Just in time, yes. It must have been weeks or months before that valley got eliminated.
及时，是的。那个山谷被消灭肯定是在几周或几个月前。
And with that, Justin found himself in a remarkable position. He had some of the very last of a species that had been around for a million years-- the last on earth. After Justin collected the snails, he packed them up and took them on a plane. The snails rode in the overhead bin. He checked them from time to time. The snails that Justin collected, along with some others that had been gathered the previous year, were sent to a handful of places that could care for them.
就这样，贾斯汀发现自己处于一个非凡的位置。他手里有一些已经存在了百万年的物种的最后一些成员——地球上的最后一些。贾斯汀收集蜗牛后，把它们装好带上了飞机。蜗牛坐在头顶行李架上。他时常检查它们。贾斯汀收集的蜗牛，以及前一年收集的一些蜗牛，被送往几个能照看它们的地方。
The plan was simple. If you could get them to breed, then you go from tens of snails to hundreds, thousands. And you could put them back in nature. Some of the snails were sent to the Bristol Zoo. Visitors would walk right by them-- no idea they were looking at what could be the last of their kind on earth.
计划很简单。如果你能让它们繁殖，那么你就从几十只蜗牛变成数百只、数千只。你可以把它们放回大自然。一些蜗牛被送到了布里斯托尔动物园。游客们会直接走过它们——完全不知道他们正在看的是地球上最后的同类。
Melissa Bushell was one of the keepers in charge of them, in the hopes that their numbers would increase-- and, I have to say, kind of the perfect person to try to pull this thing off-- dedicated, methodical, and, aside from a detour as a bartender, she can trace this career choice way back. Melissa recently transitioned, by the way. She asked that we share that.
梅丽莎·布舍尔是负责照顾它们的饲养员之一，希望它们的数量能增加——而且，我必须说，是尝试完成这件事的完美人选——敬业、有条理，除了曾有一段时间当过酒保的插曲，她可以追溯这个职业选择到很久以前。顺便说一句，梅丽莎最近完成了跨性别转换。她要求我们分享这一点。
Yeah, since I was about, maybe-- I don't know-- probably about two or three or four, I just always liked bugs and reptiles and fish and animals that weren't fluffy, basically. So yeah, it's always been a bit of a passion.
是的，从我大约，可能——我不知道——可能大约两三四岁开始，我一直喜欢虫子、爬行动物、鱼和那些不毛茸茸的动物，基本上就是这样。所以是的，这一直是一种热情。
Wait, how come not fluffy?
等等，为什么不是毛茸茸的？
Well, everyone else liked the fluffy things like monkeys and tigers. And I've kind of felt bad for the bugs and the things that people thought were a bit ick. So, you know, they needed somebody to like them as well.
嗯，其他人都喜欢毛茸茸的东西，比如猴子和老虎。我一直有点为虫子和那些人们觉得有点恶心的东西感到遗憾。所以，你知道，它们也需要有人喜欢它们。
Melissa, usually listening to classical music on the radio, would tend to the snails, feed them twice a week a mixture of porridge oats, trout food pellet, and cuddle bone ground into a powder, change out the sheet of plastic wrap that covers the top of the glass boxes they were in, and see if their numbers would increase. Melissa spent a lot of time watching them. There's a little dance they do when they mate.
梅丽莎通常听着收音机里的古典音乐，每周给蜗牛喂两次燕麦片、鳟鱼饲料颗粒和磨成粉的墨鱼骨，更换覆盖在它们所在的玻璃盒顶部的保鲜膜，看看它们的数量是否会增加。梅丽莎花了很多时间看着它们。它们交配时有一个小小的舞蹈。
Oh, it's super cute to watch.
噢，看着它们非常可爱。
What's the dance like?
那舞蹈是什么样的？
Very slow. [LAUGHS]
非常慢。[笑]
Told you.
跟你说了吧。
They kind of just end up sort of circling each other. And I'm sure each species does it slightly differently. But then one of them will sort of climb on next to the other one. And then they will touch their necks together because that's where their genitalia is. And they'll sort of mate that way.
它们最后只是围着对方绕圈。我相信每个物种的做法略有不同。但之后其中一个会爬到另一个旁边。然后它们会把脖子贴在一起，因为那是它们的生殖器所在的地方。它们会那样交配。
Genitalia is on the neck?
生殖器在脖子上？
Yeah.
是的。
They really are like an alien species.
它们确实像一个外星物种。
Mm-hmm, that's why I like invertebrates so much. They're just weird but good.
嗯，这就是为什么我这么喜欢无脊椎动物。它们很怪，但很好。
Then, a few weeks later, a baby would be born-- just the size of a period you might write with a pencil at the end of a sentence. So the breeding was working. But there was a problem.
然后，几周后，一个宝宝就会出生——只有你在句子末尾用铅笔写下的句号那么大。所以繁殖起作用了。但有一个问题。
Give me a second. I can tell you exactly how many we had. So when I started, we had 80 of them. We went from 80 at the end of 2010 to 60 in March 2011, 61 in June 2011. September 2011, 52.
给我一秒钟。我可以准确告诉你我们有多少。我刚开始的时候，我们有80只。我们从2010年底的80只变成了2011年3月的60只，2011年6月的61只。2011年9月，52只。
The snails were reproducing but not fast enough to replace the ones that were dying. No one could figure out why. I want to be sure you get a picture of just how much effort and expertise went into this. It was a whole team of people. They did autopsies of each snail when it died, taking them out of their shells, preserving them, slicing them, looking at them under a microscope.
蜗牛在繁殖，但速度不足以替代死去的那些。没人能查出原因。我想确保你能了解在这个项目上投入了多少努力和专业知识。那是一整个团队的人。每只蜗牛死亡时他们都会进行尸检，把它从壳里取出来，保存，切片，在显微镜下观察。
They even reached out to Justin, who'd rescued the last ones on the island as a grad student. Justin, thinking maybe there was a problem with the diet, went back to an old museum collection that had snails preserved from over 100 years ago. Surprisingly, he found ants in some of their stomachs. But they determined the snails probably weren't feeding on ants. The snails probably had just eaten fruit that had ants in it. No one had any idea what was wrong. Their numbers continued to drop without explanation.
他们甚至联系了贾斯汀，他作为研究生营救了岛上最后的一些蜗牛。贾斯汀思考也许饮食有问题，回到了一个有一百多年历史的老博物馆收藏中，那里有保存的蜗牛。令人惊讶的是，他在其中一些胃里发现了蚂蚁。但他们断定蜗牛可能并没有以蚂蚁为食。蜗牛可能只是吃了有蚂蚁的水果。没人知道出了什么问题。它们的数量在没有解释的情况下继续下降。
By May 2014, we were down to 17.
到2014年5月，我们剩下17只了。
Oh.
噢。
Yeah. Then June-- 14--
是的。然后六月——14只——
Oh.
噢。
--and then down to 9 on the 16th of September 2014. And then that's when they went to Edinburgh.
——然后到2014年9月16日剩下9只。然后那时它们去了爱丁堡。
Edinburgh Zoo. If there's anywhere that could save them, it was Edinburgh. If the president were sick, that's where you'd send him, if he were a snail. Years before this, Edinburgh Zoo had been sent a single snail-- the very last of its kind in captivity-- just one-- a subspecies called Partula taeniata simulans. They kept it alive. And somehow, it was pregnant. It gave birth. And soon, there were hundreds and hundreds of them. And they were put back in the wild.
爱丁堡动物园。如果有什么地方能救它们，那就是爱丁堡。如果总统病了，你会把他送到那儿，如果他是一只蜗牛的话。在这之前很多年，爱丁堡动物园收到过一只蜗牛——俘获中仅存的最后一只同类——只有一只——一个叫Partula taeniata simulans的亚种。它们让它活了下来。不知怎么的，它怀孕了。它生下了后代。很快，就有成百上千只。它们被放回了野外。
Melissa was full of worry, though-- said, when the last bean snails went up to Edinburgh Zoo in a van, it felt like handing off a grenade that the pin had just been taken out of. The situation these people were in with the bean snail, where you know you have the last ones in your hands-- it's very rare. More often, we just don't know if something's going extinct. Usually, scientists suspect something in the wild has disappeared. But there's a long process of searching and surveying to determine, yes, it's really gone. The standard is, when there's no reasonable doubt, the last individual of a species has died.
梅丽莎充满了担忧，她说，当最后一些豆蜗牛被面包车送到爱丁堡动物园时，感觉就像递出了一颗拔掉了销的手榴弹。这些人带着豆蜗牛所处的这种境地，你知道手里拿着最后一些——非常罕见。通常，我们只是不知道某种东西是否正在灭绝。通常，科学家怀疑野外的某种东西已经消失了。但有一个漫长的搜索和调查过程来确定，是的，它真的消失了。标准是，当没有合理怀疑时，物种的最后一个个体已经死亡。
This year, six new things were officially designated as extinct-- the Chinese paddlefish, three Moroccan freshwater fish, a tree from Asia, and a fly from the UK, last seen in 1907. But they weren't there yet with the bean snail. The nine remaining snails arrived at Edinburgh Zoo. The snails were not put on display but were kept instead in a quiet room-- an old coal shed, actually, where that other single snail had come back from the brink. Ross Poulter, who helped take care of them, told me he thinks the light there is perfectly dim, like it would be in the forest. He said he felt a kind of awe being in there with them.
今年，六个新物种被正式指定为灭绝——长江白鲟、三种摩洛哥淡水鱼、一种来自亚洲的树，以及一种自1907年以来最后一次见到、来自英国的苍蝇。但他们还没到豆蜗牛这一步。剩下的九只蜗牛到达了爱丁堡动物园。蜗牛没有被展出，而是被养在一个安静的房间里——其实是一个旧煤棚，也就是那只曾从边缘回来的单只蜗牛待过的地方。参与照顾它们的罗斯·波尔特告诉我，他认为那里的光线非常暗，就像森林里一样。他说他待在它们身边时感到一种敬畏。
You know, you can be in that room on your own, looking after these snails. And you peel back the cling film on the lid to reach in, and you're actually feeding the last individuals. That's it.
你知道，你可以在那个房间里独自照顾这些蜗牛。你揭开盖子上的保鲜膜伸手进去，你喂养的其实是最后的一些个体。就是这样。
He wondered, what would it be like if you had the last elephant? Within a year, eight of the snails had died, which meant they were down to one snail-- the last bean snail. Some snails can reproduce without a mate-- basically impregnate themselves. Every time he went in there, Ross would check to see if there was a baby. A month went by-- this one snail just doing its thing-- no baby. Two months, three months, six months.
他想，如果你拥有最后一只大象会是什么感觉？一年内，八只蜗牛死亡，这意味着只剩下一只——最后一只豆蜗牛。有些蜗牛没有伴侣也能繁殖——基本上自我受孕。每次进去，罗斯都会查看是否有宝宝。一个月过去了——这只蜗牛只是在做它自己的事——没有宝宝。两个月，三个月，六个月。
I remember when I went in there to do my morning checks, and it was quite clearly dead. And I do remember just standing there looking at it, thinking, it's actually very sad, you know? It was quite thought provoking.
我记得当我进去做早晨检查时，它明显死了。我确实记得只是站在那里看着它，心想，这真的非常悲伤，你知道吗？这非常发人深省。
He thought about how the famous British explorer, Captain James Cook, had been there at the beginning. And now, at the other end, him, Ross Poulter, looking at the last one.
他想到了著名的英国探险家詹姆斯·库克船长在开始时就在那里。现在，在另一端，他，罗斯·波尔特，看着最后一只。
So you have all those kind of thoughts. And I was in there on my own. And nobody else at that moment knew about it.
所以你有那种想法。我当时独自在里面。那时没人知道这件事。
I still remember vividly the day that they brought that last snail up in a little alcohol tube to preserve it for posterity. And just everyone was heartbroken.
我依然生动地记得那天他们把最后一只蜗牛放在一个小酒精管里带上来，为了后代保留它。每个人都心碎了。
This is Jo Elliott, who was overseeing things.
这是乔·艾略特，他负责监督这件事。
I mean, at the time, you get on with it. You're professional. You deal with it. But that snail-- I kept it on my desk for a long time as a reminder of what it is we're trying to do and what we're trying to avoid.
我的意思是，当时，你只能继续下去。你很专业。你处理它。但那只蜗牛——我把它放在桌子上很长一段时间，作为一个提醒，提醒我们正在努力做什么，以及我们正在努力避免什么。
Was that the first thing you'd worked with that you'd actually watched to go extinct?
那是你参与过的第一件你真正亲眼看着灭绝的东西吗？
Yep that's the only thing I've worked with that I've seen go extinct in that way. It's quite a life-changing experience.
是的，这是我参与过的唯一一件以那种方式看着灭绝的东西。这是一个相当改变人生的经历。
Yeah, I feel like, you know, it says something about our species that we're in this position in the first place.
是的，我觉得，你知道，这说明我们物种本身就处于这个位置。
Yeah, absolutely, because this was an entirely man-made situation.
是的，绝对，因为这完全是人为造成的情况。
But it also says something that there are so many people trying so hard to keep them alive.
但这也说明有很多很多人在努力让它们活下去。
Absolutely. Yeah. Yeah, both sides of the coin.
绝对。是的。是的，硬币的两面。
As far as I can tell, the end of the snail that had been around for a million years-- other than a handful of people, nobody noticed-- no stories in the papers or online. I'd wanted to know what it was like to come face to face with extinction. Ross knew. When the last one died, Ross was the one who put it in the glass jar. It's his neat handwriting on the side that says, P Faba, for partula faba. Last known individual, he wrote. I asked if he'd managed to absorb what had happened.
据我所知，这种已经存在了百万年的蜗牛的终结——除了少数人，没人注意到——报纸或网上没有报道。我一直想知道面对灭绝是什么感觉。罗斯知道。最后一只死的时候，罗斯就是那个把它放进玻璃罐的人。侧面是他整洁的字迹，写着“P Faba”，代表partula faba。他写道，“最后已知的个体”。我问他是否已经消化了发生的事情。
He said, I don't know how to answer that. Even when you see it up close, it's hard to understand. It's too big. It's not on our time scale at all. You'd have to somehow be able to imagine snails being born one generation after another for, like, a million years and then it stopping-- in Ross' case, on some Sunday at the office before your very eyes. What are you supposed to do after that?
他说，我不知道该怎么回答。即使你近距离看到它，也很难理解。它太大了。这根本不在我们的时间尺度上。你必须以某种方式想象蜗牛一代又一代地出生，持续一百万年，然后停止——在罗斯的情况下，在某个星期天的办公室里，就在你眼前。那之后你应该做什么？
We're so used to stories about people on deadline facing one last chance to save things and figuring out some way at the last moment. But I think the truth is when you get to the point where things are so desperate, they are down to one last chance, it's rarely a good one. I know. That's a terrible way to end a story. But it's a fact.
我们习惯了关于在截止日期前的人们面临最后机会拯救事物，并在最后一刻找到某种方法的报道。但我认为真相是，当你到达情况如此绝望的地步，只剩下最后一次机会时，它很少会是好结果。我知道。这是一个糟糕的结束故事的方式。但这是一个事实。
David Kestenbaum is our show's Senior Editor.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆是我们节目的高级编辑。
Well, our program was produced by Sean Cole. The people who put together today's program include Elna Baker, Michael Comite, Valerie Kipnis, Miki Meek, Katherine Rae Mondo, Michelle Navarro, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Charlotte Sleeper, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our Managing Editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our Executive Editor is Emanuele Berry.
好吧，我们的节目是由肖恩·科尔制作的。今天共同制作节目的还有艾尔娜·贝克、迈克尔·科米特、瓦莱丽·基普尼斯、三木·米克、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、米歇尔·纳瓦罗、斯托·尼尔森、纳迪亚·雷曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、夏洛特·斯利珀、弗朗西斯·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。我们的执行编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的执行主编是埃马努埃莱·贝里。
Special thanks today to Maria Hollenhorst, Craig Hilton-Taylor, Justine Paradis, Jack Rodolico, Katie Colaneri, Ed Spiker, Dan Barrick, Maureen McMurray, Stephen Andersen, Susan Solomon, Robert Watson, Joseph Steed, and Jim Baker. Our website is thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there are videos. There are lists of favorite shows if you're looking for something to listen to and tons of other stuff there. Again, thisamericanlife.org.
特别感谢今天的玛丽亚·霍伦霍斯特、克雷格·希尔顿-泰勒、贾斯汀·帕拉迪斯、杰克·罗多利科、凯蒂·科拉内里、埃德·斯派克、丹·巴里克、莫琳·麦克默里、斯蒂芬·安徒生、苏珊·所罗门、罗伯特·沃森、约瑟夫·斯蒂德和吉姆·贝克。我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以绝对免费地在线收听我们超过750集的档案。此外，还有视频。如果你正在寻找可以听的东西，还有喜欢的节目列表以及大量其他东西。再次说明，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, we were at the car rental place the other day. We waited in line forever. The rental people were so rude. Finally, Torey just lost it. He said, we're going somewhere else-- Avis, Enterprise, Hertz-- anyplace but this place.
《美国生活》通过公共广播交流中心PRX发送给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，前几天我们在汽车租赁处。我们排队等了很久。租赁的人非常粗鲁。最后，托雷崩溃了。他说，我们要去别的地方——AVIS、企业、赫兹——除了这儿哪儿都行。
This Budget just does not work.
这份预算根本行不通。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来，带着更多《美国生活》的故事。